lot of the phone is by far our biggest
game yet and this time around it's big
in terms of gameplay as well quite a lot
of effort went into the combat system
specifically and quite a lot of depth to
tech wise instead of using a commercial
engine we actually wrote our own engine
called Fletch much supported pc
playstation 3 xbox 360 and iOS and now
obviously playstation 4 and xbox one a
lot of people really called us crazy
that we developing our own engine but in
the end I think it was really worth it
when thinking about the biggest
challenges ringing existing tech over to
a new generation of hardware is one
thing but making a child and optimize it
for a specific platforms really a
totally different story we put a lot of
effort into a new lighting and material
system lighting really makes the
difference on the current generation of
gaming hardware and that's what's also
the artists really try to push Fletch
currently is capable of handling
hundreds of dynamic lights or casting
shadows projected textures every surface
in the game is able to reflect light the
bounds of indirect diffuse lighting so
we put a lot of effort into this kind of
system a lot of work has been done to
get the physics integration right as
well a good example for this would be
how the cloth simulation interact with
the character animations and the time
and effort put into this really shows to
create this world of lots of the foil we
had the real big task to create a really
immersive and detailed world within this
next console generation it's used a very
complex lighting approach because most
people would really expect that this
game is dark and mature and gray and
black really wanted to make a unique
style we came up with instancing idea
which really helped us to get these
thousands of assets into the next
generation consoles and with support of
hundreds of artists around the world we
were really happy with the result and
fletch is really capable of these really
modern technique